the algorithm is not my enemy the
algorithm is my friend welcome to do it
on a dime hi guys do it on a dime here
and this is over 10 years over
335 million views how did you start
YouTube in the first place and how you
got here today I found that short form
content is an amazing way to drive
viewership to my channel so I would see
something start to Trend or be like whoo
like I have something to say here and
start to Pivot my content toward
that welcome back to the think media
podcast in today's episode we're going
to be learning from a creator that is
getting 2.8 million views per month
right now she's going to be breaking
down her strategies her tips but she's
also been on YouTube for over a decade
so there's going to be some Priceless
insights for not just how to start a new
channel but how to succeed over the Long
Haul and the ups and downs that come
with a Creator career uh Catherine from
do it on a dime it shares her passion
for organizing frugal living and DIY
across the internet with a message that
living your best life on a budget is
achievable for anyone so if you're short
on money and time she is your go-to girl
and her mission is to help you create a
beautiful organized Lifestyle on a
Frugal budget and today we get to learn
from all of her YouTube secrets and tips
Katherine welcome to the show what's up
Sean I'm so glad to be here this is
awesome so we actually got to talk six
seven years ago different Channel video
influencers and uh you already had built
um a powerful Channel by that time but
now you've been still doing it you've
been still going and uh over 10 years
over
335 million views um tell people a
little bit about your story of how did
you start YouTube in the first place and
how you got here today oh man Sean I
remember that interview I remember I was
like eight months pregnant and that was
at our old house I mean I I'm a teacher
by trade hey so I was born and raised in
Detroit I came down to North Carolina
and I had a teaching career and you know
obviously as a teacher I didn't make a
lot of money and so there were everybody
at that time this was back like Circa
you know 2012 2013 was posting all these
haul videos that was just really in
style and so and everything was so
expensive and I was like well I can't
afford that I'm a pretty organized
person so I was shopping a lot at the
dollar store and I'm like nobody is
sharing this at all and so I didn't have
any training I just had a lot of passion
I was a middle school teacher so I'm
quirky right so I just like I pick up a
flip camera and I filmed my first video
in January of 2012 and looking back I'm
like man I had hit a tent pole right
already January everyone's looking to
get organized and save money hey so that
was you know my first video was how to
organize your home on a tight budget and
I put it out there expected nothing to
happen and I came back a few months
later to thousands of views and people
were interested it was during the
recession and so it truly was a
serendipitous start to YouTube but as I
started creating content and developing
an audience I was like man there's
really something here um you know one
thing as somebody who's been doing this
for a really long time is I think really
early on I adopted a strategy of the
pivot right so I would see something
start to Trend or be like whoa like I
have something to say here and start to
Pivot my content toward that and then
things just started snowballing so you
talk about that 1% better when creators
you know I feel like a lot of people say
like just double down on what works you
know like that's what what I was
actually doing I didn't realize I was
doing it but I would start to create
more content you know involving the
dollar store eventually for a little
while I had a family channel um but you
know things really started to take off
for me um and then eventually I got to
the spot where I was able to quit my
teaching job and pursue YouTube
full-time and this was right around 2018
or so after my son was born um and we
had a lot of Life stuff that was
happening and then you know the upcoming
pandemic right um but people when people
were stuck in their homes you know do it
on a dime really succeeded during that
time and I think there's always a niche
of people looking to make their homes
better and do so affordably and so what
I've done to just sustain this brand is
take this same story right start it off
in the same place and just pivot it
through different lenses and I I love
what I do I now you know work full-time
with my husband at this I have a small
team behind me um and you know on
different platforms just keeping my hand
on all the burners or not my hand that
would be a bad idea the pots on all the
burners and uh yeah here we are so man
your story is so inspiring and I want to
go back to it sounds like what 2012 2011
to 20 the first four years it took four
years before you took the leap and left
your teaching job correct it did and I
know that was at time too when nobody
was really doing that like there was
push back from people in my life they're
like you're going to do YouTube full
time like what is that um and it was it
was scary because I was taking something
that was kind of an unknown variable but
but also it you know I had some trust in
myself at that point because that was
when I really started to work with
Brands a lot more consistently and I was
like there's some real opportunity here
to reach more people if I have more time
for my YouTube channel and just like as
a human being too like we only have so
much bandwidth in the day and I think
looking back at myself early on like I I
was hustling so hard like trying to wear
all the hats um and I think as soon as I
stepped out and I said you know this is
what I'm pursuing full-time there was
kind of like almost an ease in that I'm
like okay now I have like my focus right
you know I'm only focusing on these few
things and I I want to make them great
um and for me those things have always
been my family first and um you know my
job and my sanity has to be a part of
that in there too and so if you were
giving some advice to creators I love
your advice um about eventually taking a
leap getting focused and obviously you
had momentum at that time and it was a
calculated risk but while you were in
that season of the side hustle where you
were juggling so many things what are
some of the things that helped you
create content balance family maybe it
balance is the wrong word But ultimately
get through those four years where so
many creators are they're there may be
already monetized there's money coming
in there's a brand deal or two but
there's still that Gap give some advice
for The Gap yeah the Gap I mean balance
is still an elusive word for me I'll be
honest like I I would love to like oh
yes I'm so balanced I I think honestly
the um the mindset for most creators
that gets you into this there is
something about you that likes to be
creative you like to push yourself you
like to try new things and I think
sometimes that doesn't necessarily
translate to creating balance or like a
a business that sustains right because
you're balancing like this creative mind
with this like only so many hours in the
day so really as I hunkered down like I
had to reverse engineer exactly what I
wanted and then Plug and Play the things
that would allow me to get there like
truly ask myself what is it that I want
like what number makes sense for our
family so that we can go full-time cool
how do I do that what are the five
things I have in place right now that's
allowing me to be able to get there how
much time a week do I want with my
family when am I going to schedule in my
breaks and when am I going to like
double down and hustle hard um and just
giving myself an outline and was it
perfect no my gosh like things came up
all the time life got life real quick
but at the same time just having like
casting that vision for myself about
what balance looked like for me allowed
me to fill in the gaps and for a lot I
think for a lot of creatives especially
early on we work really hard and then as
we get into it we're like I need to stop
working hard and working smarter do you
know what I'm saying like I I was
working so hard and doing all of these
things and I realized hey I don't have
to be producing two videos a week I can
make more money producing one longer
quality video than two videos a week and
doing especially now like in today's
environment and doing a few shorts right
so I I'm really looking at what output
is going to involve sustainability for
me and get the most out of it I can make
more money producing one higher quality
video than two especially now in today's
environment what do you mean by that so
I well right now the YouTube algorithm
definitely favors longer content I can
run more ads on that content and
everything in my experience on my
channel has been all about watch time if
I can get that watch time up and I can
get that click-through rate pretty high
people are coming they're staying that
video is going to get served to more
people and so especially now and this is
such good news too for like people just
starting out those brand new creators
like it is very possible to get a really
high number of views on a video so some
videos that would have gotten you know
half the views all of a sudden I'm
doubling my viewership because it's
longer and for me I found that short
form content is an amazing way to drive
viewership to my Channel um and so kind
of the way that breakdown looks for me
because I always like to hear when
people like actually give the specifics
of their channel right so what I will do
is Tik Tok is my sandbox um I don't make
a single scent from Tik Tok I never have
but I will post videos short form
content on Tik Tok that is like you know
break down like smaller segments of
successful parts of YouTube videos and I
see what performs over there if that
video performs on Tik Tok I know it's
going to do really well on YouTube so
I'll pull those videos and put them on
YouTube of that high performing content
now it's going to get served in front of
more eyeballs my channel continues to
grow and then it's more likely that
those viewers are going to watch that
longer form content so I I all of a
sudden had that strategy developed so
now I don't have to make two long you
know fully produced YouTube videos I
need some really strategic shorts that
are going to drive viewership to those
other videos such a powerful strategy
that you're doing there and to Define
long form watch time if I break down
your channel I look at your most recent
uploads long form it seems like is
between over eight minutes so you could
have multiple ad spots to around 11
minutes that seems to be the sweet spot
for the last uh 10 20 videos 15 it looks
like one of them um is that what you
mean by long form that is what I mean
and I guess this I should clarify that
too because that's different for every
Creator like some creators I know um
that have very successful channels that
I you know I work with they they are
posting hourong videos and that's but
that's done really well for them and it
might not do as well out the gate for
them but over time if people are
watching a larger percent of that video
I used to make content that was super
short form I'm talking like three to
four minute videos and those performed
really well for a time and then I had to
Pivot off of that because they stopped
performing as well and I realized that
that over eight minute Mark for me
that's a long video really packed with
tips it almost trips over itself that's
keeping that watch time high so powerful
now over 12
years um have you ever felt burnt out
being um even now in the season with
okay we got a team and my husband's
helping me and I've got resource and
money coming in but have you been able
to avoid burnout has there any been
seasons of burnout and what advice would
you give to creators to stay healthy
emotionally physically mentally oh man I
feel like this is a any creator that I
talk to struggles with this because I
feel like there's there's an element of
social media that's very hamster whe
right like it's like you always got to
have something new I have felt burnt out
many times and typically it's usually
about once a year that I start to feel
like oh my gosh like I don't know if I
can handle all of this you know we went
through a season um that was really
challenging for my family it was shortly
after my brother had passed away my
husband got diagnosed with um Crohn's
disease which is a really gnarly illness
and we were having trouble managing that
and I just like that season in
particular was one of intense burnout
for me um it was really hard for me to
want to show up online and do this and I
think I I think I handled it okay but I
think what I have to remember is I am in
this for the Long Haul right and me
working harder isn't going to give me
any better content so like even if I
doubled down and I tried and I did all
of these things I'm just making myself
not able to be creative and work later
and so I did have to pull back there
were weeks that I didn't post and I I
literally for me that felt like
catastrophic like the world is over I'm
not doing what I'm supposed to be doing
and I know that sounds intense but like
as a creative like I really wanted that
was a big part of my day but it it
turned out okay and taking those rests
and those breaks were really important
um I place a big value on Mental Health
on spending time with my family and I
think I really learned that in that
season that slowing down was okay I was
okay and in some ways it was actually a
gift because it taught me that there are
times when I can actually do less things
it's okay and there's a better outcome
it was actually right around that time
that I realized I don't need to be
posting two videos AEK week I'm better
off creating one solid piece of content
that performs much better um and so you
know over and sometimes it's hard to
have that you know 10,000 foot up view
when you're like in the trenches right
but I think there is a lot of value in
times of my life where I've been like
quiet and listening and reflective and
then times when I have the opportunity
to be more creative and step out and try
new things so just like recognizing that
part of yourself and knowing all right
this is when I'm slowing down for a bit
and re-evaluating and now here is the
time where I get to step out and try
something new it makes me think of the
power of seasons and I feel like you've
been through we all every listener has
been through Seasons um it's like
biblical it says as long as the Earth
remains summer fall winter spring like
they'll be seasons and and and the Very
World itself kind of gives us that
there's life is seasonal uh question for
you and you kind of touched on this you
started in a particular economic season
which was jet fuel for your channel um
and those Cycles continue to to happen
of course and so you've been through a
lot in the context of now doing this
over a decade what have you learned
about Seasons how it relates to your
family how it relates to being a Creator
how it relates to maybe seasons of
growth and I think one of the big
emotions that can also hit creators to
your point about the pandemic our views
doubled as soon as the lockdown started
from no effort of our own just our back
catalog we were actually getting about
222 122,000 views was kind of just
real-time views because of a library of
content ranked videos from suggested in
Search and then boom it went to a
quarter million we kept posting and and
things got got crazy but literally a
seasonal shift something externally that
happened in the world so from your
standpoint what are some of the lessons
you've learned about Seasons that from
you have a vantage point that most
listening to this have not been doing
this 12 years what are your thoughts on
seasons in your life oh man I would say
embrace the season and embrace it wildly
because even if I look big picture at my
content what I am doing 10 years ago is
not different I'm still shopping at the
dollar store a lot I'm still organizing
houses I'm still motivating people and
there's a joy and like lightness about
my channel I love doing it but in each
season I just took what I wanted to
share and I put it through a new lens
like if you want to like take the
analogy further you could even think
about like it's winter time I'm going to
put on a jacket I'm gonna put on a scarf
I'm gonna go outside I'm not gonna run
outside in a bathing suit and like rail
against the system and be like I can't
believe I'm so cold right now right so I
mean even just thinking back to the
pandemic times like there was this day I
remember like it was like the whole face
mask thing and I I literally like made
no there was nothing out there about
face masks and they were sold out
everywhere so I made this video about
how to like DIY a face mask mask I put
it live and immediately it was number
three un trending and I was like holy
cow and it was a little bit accidental
like I didn't even actually I didn't
think that many people would watch that
right but all of a sudden it's it's big
and it's out there and I'm not saying
that it has to be you know so direct
like that but to take things that are
trending or the season of social media
and I I really tend to see a lot of
these things first and this is my
experience but start appearing on Tik
Tok especially in the DIY space Tik Tok
is kind of like the origin of a lot of
these Seasons um you there was a while
that organization was really really in
people wanted to figure out how to
organize and then minimalism really
started trending and decluttering and so
how can I take the story that I'm
already telling and apply it to this new
season which is more minimalism
generated um and there was a concept
that I came across was called Swedish
death cleaning and those videos
performed really well for me that's one
of my most viewed videos and it had to
do with decluttering the things that um
you know don't serve you in your life
and it has like kind of a ringy title
right and so and my content was the same
it's the same content But the lens was
just a little bit different so as you
see those things changing whether it's
politically socially whether it's in
your Niche just leaning your content
into that and trying to see like okay
what if I tried this angle does this
work for me how can I um because I do
find a lot of creators that I talk to
they'll say like oh like the algorithm
like these videos just aren't getting
views these used to get views and for me
like the algorithm is not my enemy the
algorithm is my friend um it it is
really a powerful tool and telling you
this is the type of way that people want
to come across content find it and click
on it like are you allowing your content
to be a part of that or are you just
saying railing against it so yeah that
that seasonality metaphor is is a really
powerful one they oftentimes some of the
best people at predicting what's going
to happen in the future are those that
have the best understanding of history
and what's happened in the past and
there are R are few people that have
again over a decade of YouTube
experience and have stayed in it and
have stayed consistent during that
entire time of course the future is
uncertain but what are some of your
predictions right now as a creator that
you're paying attention to you mentioned
politically economically there's a lot
of the the the the economy is insane
right now it seems like it's somewhat
steady yet people say recession's here
and the whole thing's about to fall
apart do you worry about that too much
worries the wrong word do you how
thoughtful are you and what are some
moves you're making right now or
intentions you're making right now to be
thoughtful so that you could be prepared
and be ready or be ready to the word you
used pivot what are some things you're
seeing coming down the line for creators
man that's a that's a really loaded
question I think you know for there's
certain things I see coming down the
line for myself um but just in general I
feel like in the Creator space shorts
like shorts are King obviously like
shorts are getting so many views whether
I mean Facebook oh my gosh like they've
almost exclusively moved over to short
form content but I feel like we sort of
operate on this pendulum of extremes
where shorts are really in in right now
but also long form content and I'm not
talking about the eight minute long form
I'm talking like long form content like
this right like hourlong uploads podcast
content you see like almost these
bookends of things being really powerful
and so I'm starting to look at as a
Creator how can I you know level up my
shorts game how can I allow my content
to be really powerful shorts and
leverage that um because I don't you
know I don't know what that's going to
look like and it that's a really hard
thing I think for if you're used to
creating one type of content you know
like just because you make online video
doesn't mean you're necessarily going to
be good at making shorts right so I've
had to practice that it's almost like
being in the learner seat again and
reminding being like okay this is what's
trending this is the way that it's
trending do what how do my hooks look
like how long are people watching for
how is this performing and why um and so
that is something that I'm seeing a lot
of um I'm also seeing a lot of like
return back to like kind of raw and
gritty and less polished type content on
all platforms as being something you
know that people really want to consume
I think consumers are a lot more mindful
now too which has been really
interesting especially because I you
know do a lot of things with the dollar
store um thrifting and how those markets
are looking is something that I tend to
pay attention to but in general I think
regardless of what happens like you
asked the question like am I afraid or
you know worried or anything like that
and I think of all the creators and Sean
I absolutely feel like you fall into
this category too because you are you
are like me we're like the geriatric
people of like the internet right like
truly if you look at it like we have
been doing this for so long and I feel
like the people who really stay in the
game are people who stay curious like
you can see their curiosity when you
talk to them in their content and they
have found their voice and Authority
right so you feel their Authority and
their curiosity almost at the same time
um and I know you know you do this super
well in your interviews and like the
things that you've gleaned you can tell
how you're also the authority as you're
listening to other creators and so being
in the learner seat listening to my
audience having their voice be a part of
my videos right um I think all of those
things people really respond to that in
a really powerful way and I I know a lot
of creators who have stayed in the game
for a really long time and a lot of us
are like man if there's one more app
that comes out I'm GNA Kus this is so
much work but at the same time I I
really feel like I don't have a fear of
me being able to Pivot into those things
if I stay curious if I stay willing and
I keep doing what I'm doing if that
makes sense there's there's a path that
will open up and it's probably not even
one that I could predict because it
never is do you know what I'm saying
it's like always one that comes out of
the blue and you're like oh that okay
I'm curious enough to follow this down
and see what happens I know that was a
little like cerebral but I hope that
made sense what I was trying to say if
you're looking to get your first th000
subscribers or make your first $1,000 on
YouTube then join our free YouTube
challenge that many other small creators
have joined and seen tons of success
during this free challenge Sean is going
to share some of the best strategies for
growing to your first 1,000 subscribers
on YouTube as well as making your first
$1,000 just go to tube1 challenge.com or
check the link down in the description
incredible insights there and I want to
go back you mentioned
vertical video for example on Facebook
is blowing up you are using Tik Tok as a
place to experiment verify an idea turn
that into a short and it pretty much is
guaranteed to work a YouTube short how
active are you across platforms and how
would you tiar platforms for you in
terms of priority where you're uploading
are you uploading your fulllength
highquality YouTube videos to Facebook
are you able to monetize on any other
platforms what is your crossplatform
strategy this is right now today and
that I feel like I'm in the pivot right
now like right now feels like a big
pivot for me YouTube is stilling in my
opinion like YouTube is where the money
is honestly it's where the AdSense money
is um it's where the brand deals come
from like YouTube is my bread and butter
that is not going anywhere YouTube is a
platform that I think is such a solid
that is like when I people ask what I do
I say I'm a YouTuber right like that is
where things start for me but I think
that there is a lot of value in
diversifying some um for a while I
actually wasn't putting anything on
Facebook for years um and then I hired a
company to help me do my Facebook
because I just did not have the
bandwidth and I was making pretty decent
money uploading my long form content
onto Facebook but that started changing
recently meta is just like doing its
whole own thing um and Facebook tends to
do that change very rapidly and so as
the ads have change have changed there
it seems like short form content is
really starting to evolve you know
Instagram went from you know carousels
and static post to basically only reals
as the way to grow so I am only posting
reals on Instagram now and then you know
Tik Tok it's very I want to say easy to
go viral but there's a lot of
possibility for you to go viral on Tik
Tok and see what the community is
responding to especially those like
people who may not know who you are
right Tik Tok is so transient and I
don't think there's a very strong sense
of community in my experience on Tik Tok
the community I feel very much on
YouTube but all of these are kind of
pulse points for me right like if I'm
looking at myself as a YouTube Creator I
serve my a audience that comes to my
YouTube videos within that video what
are the most Salient points in other
words the highest watch time you can see
that little graph right the Gray Line
where are people watching they're
sticking around here let me turn that
into a short because that's a sound bite
so for me I kind of look at it as a web
and YouTube is the center and that well
could change I don't know um Facebook
was kind of you know starting to come
into that as well as like a a really big
performer for me but now it's it's very
different like there isn't as much
revenue on Facebook and so I'm pivoting
off of that I'm keeping that you know
pot on the stove as it were because you
never know but I think the biggest thing
overall is obviously to have a platform
like YouTube that allows you to have
those long form content and create that
Community but just be willing and ready
to to try new things in other places and
take the stuff you're already making and
just repackaging again you're just like
this is what I've got how can I
repackage this and see if I can um you
know what people respond to and is there
a difference between would a vertical
video that ends up getting cut out of a
video via Facebook reel also go on Tik
Tok also go as a YouTube short are you
creating original shorts from the ground
up or vertical videos that also might be
an Instagram reel a Facebook reel and we
can also transition into maybe talking
about how a team is supporting you as
anybody's mind listening to this you
start thinking about that you go man I
even just managing the distribution of
content in and of itself can get kind of
wild and so is that something you tackle
or do you have now like a social media
manager somebody that's kind of helping
um DJ out especially vertical video
across platforms yeah so I do have help
um and my husband is a big help in
editing of those vertical videos but I
the one thing that I will say is it
sounds like a lot but if you think about
it as my main video is like my Homebase
pulse point right and then from that I'm
going to extract shorts typically
all of the video footage I'm extracting
from the YouTube video and then I play
with it in different ways I am not
Reinventing the wheel every time
sometimes I will go back to videos that
I made four five years ago that content
like people don't remember that right
like this especially because we move
like we live in such a fast-paced world
right people don't remember something
you posted last week so I will take
content that I know is really high
performing from old videos and put those
into shorts so if I'm really thinking
about it those pieces that I'm pulling
out this one strong concept I now have
three angles those are three different
videos for shorts um and I experiment
some videos are the audio is extracted
directly from the YouTube video I post
some I do a voice up on it um to try to
get a hook or to try to see if I can get
people to stay what are people
responding to some I want to include my
face in it you know the first three
seconds is seeing a face how does that
you know in increase or decrease
engagement um and I think because of
YouTube is really like a a deck for me
people can go back to videos that I
posted three years ago and all of a
sudden I'm looking at my dashboard and
I'm like this video I posted four years
ago is one of my most watched this month
YouTube is like you know a roll aex of
information and it's constantly
resurfacing old content whereas short
form content is very fresh of the moment
this is within like the last three weeks
so there's nothing wrong with taking
content that maybe you know is good the
YouTube video showed it was good and
repackaging it in a couple of weeks in a
new format right to see like how can I
change the hook how can I change the
intro to this and right now because this
is new I do have a pretty big hand in
you know creating some of those um but
it has been really nice to have you know
a small team of people to be able to
bounce ideas off of to um that offer
different insights whether it's with
creative or editing to get some of those
like Basics out of the way so I'm just
working with like the skeleton and we
can play with it from there you're
breaking down some very tactical
insights that we can apply and maybe
even moving into a more advanced
conversation in the sense that for those
that start adding a team that's a a
whole pivot point of enough Revenue
coming in and getting to that level um
how big is your team now and honestly I
will say Sean like my my team is smaller
than most people's teams I would think
at the number of like if you want to
look at like subscriber numbers or
viewership or whatever but I I still do
a lot of editing of videos myself like I
am the primary final editor of all of my
main YouTube content that goes out I
enjoy that I enjoy that storytelling and
messing with the metrics to get that
watch time up it's something that I I
enjoy but right now my husband works
with me so I helped you know train him
on how to use Final Cut Pro that's what
I used to edit um and then I have an
assistant that runs and she's virtual
that runs all of my social media pages
so she addresses comments on Facebook
YouTube Instagram all that sort of thing
um and then I have an assistant that is
you know working with me on DIY projects
shopping and helping just kind of like
make these Transformations come to life
so we can you know turn them quickly
because a lot of the DIY project
especially if you're in the DIY space
man like that is talk about like
physical burnout you're doing like a lot
of stuff right in the background so um
and then I have you know a company that
I hired to help with my Facebook page
and they are also remote and they are
taking my content and just you know
putting it on Facebook and helping it
get in front of eyeballs so it's really
a team of about like six people that I'm
working with um and it's they're not all
full-time it's you know mostly part-time
virtual contract type work um but it's
it's really worked for the season of
life that I'm in and helped given me
more balance um but all this to say I
think when I started this is only in the
last couple of years that this that you
know the word team has even been a part
of that that story right um this is
something that has transitioned for me
over time and gradually like I would be
able to because I was doing it myself
very clearly see okay if I want to have
more time in day and more bandwidth this
is something that I can pass off and
being willing to do that um and kind of
doing that slowly not feeling like it
was like this big thing that I had to
like you know whatever finding those
people who could help and then training
them right to be able to help um allowed
me to have a little bit more time in the
day and I could devote to other things
so it didn't come fast for me it was
slow but I know that the people that
I've selected and the roles that they
have are intentional that will help grow
my business um and so I'm really
grateful for it I'm curious back when
you say you take a five-year old short
uh 5-year-old YouTube video maybe
resurfaces and then you turn it into a
short today are you organized enough
that you're going to tap into a timeline
or the original footage or are you just
grabbing your YouTube video maybe
downloading that and then revoice
overing it or throwing that into a
timeline right now um there's a video
that I have going back it every year
this happens this particular video comes
back up again what I am doing right now
is I am downloading that YouTube video
and I am turning it into vertical format
and I have experimented with refiling
things or as I'm filming a YouTube video
I know there's real fancy cameras you
can get that allow you to film like
short form you know like vertical style
as well as like horizontal at the same
time sometimes I have my phone with me
and I'll do like some pickups vertical
just because it's easier to see the
space but on honestly I have had shorts
do very very well not having to do that
I have found especially on Tik Tok yeah
Tik Tok and um and YouTube itself if the
content if the quality of the content is
there and you have that great hook
people are interested people will stick
around it doesn't really matter um at
least for the content that I'm producing
that's been my experience who is the
money manager QuickBooks how do you uh
do business finances you guys tackle
that yourself we we do we do have a
financial adviser and my husband is just
like super into that he's he's on
YouTube watching all those he like
genuinely loves that so that's sort of
that's sort of his bag got you and then
are you managing the brand deals or does
one of the assistants also help you go
back and forth negotiate filter I have
found it is really nice to not for me
not to be the person negotiating with
Brands just so I can focus on the
creative aspect of that um and I do have
an assistant and my husband to help with
brand deal negotiation um but I will say
like and this is just speaking super
honestly like brand deals have slowed
down a lot I think for a lot of creators
and the amount of revenue from Brand
deals is a lot lower than it used to be
and I think that's twofold one brands
are scared because the economy is really
up in the air right and two I think a
lot of brands are working with honestly
like small small creators and people
with like really micro influencers and
smaller influencers that have they're
doing really successful work with a lot
of Brands because it's less expensive
right for Brands to do that um and if
they have a lot of small micro
influencers they're able to reach a
similar size audience a lot of the time
um and so a brand deals while they're
wonderful um and I have some brands that
I love working with um consistency for
me and working with Brands multiple
times is what I'm really looking for
like trusted long-term Partnerships um
that's been really good but I think for
me um affiliate marketing and course
creation is kind of like the new Avenue
for me that I'm sort of branching off
into again we're talking about the pivot
right that I'm seeing like this is a
space for my brand that that makes a lot
of sense for me to go into and so uh ad
Revenue affiliate marketing course
creation brand deals for income streams
are those the main ones you do anything
else yes those are the main those are
the main income streams right now um and
you know there's I've toyed around with
the idea of you know having another
Channel or starting a podcast or those
types of things but I haven't had the
bandwith bandwidth yet to do it so I
haven't um but I know I do have some
merchandise that I sell too but that's
um kind of a smaller income stream for
me so two days ago at the time of
recording you did 50 new Dollar Tree
deals that you need to
buy uh from the pro
and I was watching this video it seems
like it's being filmed on a gimbal who
is the videographer that's my
husband that is literally my husband and
we like honestly we are super low Tech
and maybe I don't know if maybe this is
in encouraging to hear but like I I I
have tried um hiring out or you know
having videographers or whatever it is
but I have found that honestly and
earnestly for me just filming on a
really quality DSLR camera with a nice
lens um my husband knows how to film and
we we go into the store together because
I'm often like you know in stores and so
having something smaller profile is
better and yeah we we just filmed
together and we hit those beats that
video in particular my son happened to
be there that day and it you know it it
was it was part of the story and it
worked out so and the audio is also
really good for you talking in the store
so are you miked up with like a wireless
microphone yep he's sitting right here I
got my little task cam right here um and
I I do think audio obviously is King as
well like I I think when people tune in
those are the first two things that
they're there for if the audio is bad
they're going to notice and if the
content is bad they're going to leave
right so if you if you can get your
audio and what you're saying with that
great hook and just delivering from the
beginning that's going to really really
hook an audience and you've been doing
this for so long have you found that you
just go into the store just start
filming are you trying to get permission
and have you also ran into any
challenges with music playing in the
background ever or anything like that
and copyright strikes I know there's
people curious about creating content at
Walmart at Dollar Store what are your
tips I think for me I there there have
been times when I have people have said
your managers have said like hey you
can't film in here but honestly for the
most part there are some stores that
even encourage it now because so many
people are sharing on Tik Tok there's a
store pop shelf which is an offshoot of
the Dollar General and they want you to
come in and film um you know they love
when creators are you know influencers
Nano influencers micro micro influencers
whoever it is comes in and films
anything they they want to see that out
there because that's free promotion for
them um and so there have been sometimes
where I might get some strange looks but
typically when I go into a store um I
befriend the managers I get to know
people I think that you know Community
is everything right so I make sure that
I know the managers they know me um and
I usually do three takes the first take
is me generally walking through the
store and it's pretty like low energy
and then I do like the middle of the
road take and then I do the really high
energy take at the end like right before
I was supposed to leave I have asked
stores before to turn down the music for
copyright and that's you know on an
employee and storeby store basis I'm
like hey the music's a little loud this
is what we're doing I'm Katherine this
is what I do it's so nice to meet you
you know for the next 10 minutes or so
would you be willing to turn down the
music at all this is typically in
smaller stores I'm talking like Dollar
Store size um and people people do do
that but I have run into stuff in
Walmart before in post I can sometimes
correct the audio a little bit um and
sometimes I end up just doing voiceover
too so I can you know if the song is
kind of quiet we can do a quick take and
then I can voice over it when I'm home
before we transition to the next
question you mentioned your son in that
video and it was so cool to see him I
have a one-year-old old and a
three-year-old you've got some 10 12
year old uh age was that what it was 10
10 year old yep 10year old and a
seven-year old and uh 10 and seven
what's it been like in general just
having family involved in your videos or
just how what does it feel like having a
YouTube business that can support the
vision for family having Freedom working
from home yeah I mean really that is one
of the mo that is one of the coolest
things about this job is having the
freedom to be with my family more more
and that was genuinely something that my
husband and I talked about when he came
on you know to work with me because we
talked about well you know he could stay
in corporate and then you know we might
have to get child care for our kids and
I was like or he could come and work
with me and we could you know reverse
engineer our day to figure out how we
could make this happen um and you know
something I'm a big advocate of is you
know working with a spouse especially
that's working as a family in general
that is a very different Dynamic than
you know the dayto day and so I'm a huge
advocate of therapy um right before we
started working together like we got in
therapy to just like really like
understand one another and our goals and
what we wanted out of this experience um
to make sure that it was a healthy and a
good one that we wanted to stick with
and we did have to make some changes
early on um my kids are not a huge part
of my content they're sometimes involved
in my videos um I used to have a family
channel but we sort of moved away from
that and it's I mean it's funny my son
you know always jokes around like
somebody had recognized me when we were
out and he was like why is that person
so excited to see you Mommy you're kind
of boring and I was like
thank you for that so I you know I think
they are aware that we make YouTube
videos and stuff but are not necessarily
a huge part of it unless you know
serendipitously they happen to be there
you know for something um but I I truly
think there is a lot of as the more you
create content and this takes time this
is not something that came out the gate
we didn't execute it perfectly but
allowing giving yourself um a work day
that allows for more family time and
again this goes back to working smarter
not how harder like these are the areas
that I'm working really hard in and the
spaces and the times so that I have this
more intentional and really present
family time and that's been one of the
greatest gifts um of this job honestly
is is more of that family time but for
me I had to get really intentional about
it because early on I I it was really
hard for me I could not get that balance
right where I maybe it was felt like
balanced out here but I didn't feel
balanced um and so it took it took a
while and you know like back to the
seasons thing right there's seasons of
grind and hustle and there's seasons of
like reflection and reassessment um but
I I do think right now we're in a we're
in a good spot with that and it's been
it's been nice we get to you know go
hang out as a family at you know three
o'clock on a Tuesday there's nothing
like the freedom that comes from a
Creator business but it takes a lot of
work to get there and the work is worth
it um we're going to go to our new
segment in just a second I do before
that also want to hear a shout out to
where people can connect with you but I
have actually a question you're 18
videos away from your a thousandth
upload did you know that I didn't even
realize that I didn't know that so have
you made plans yet to celebrate a
thousand uploads I have not made plans
for a thousand uploads but now I feel
like I have something I could add to the
calendar that's a good idea I think I
think you could do some kind of I mean
maybe something for your subscribers
something for your community but uh for
what it's worth I know for me
um I could get so focused on building
building building that sometimes I don't
actually uh do a celebration you deserve
it you you as a family too should do
many things you got and you have some
Runway 18 videos it's going to be a
couple weeks but you can do something
really cool and that is a huge milestone
especially for some I I've one of our uh
think media podcast interviews was
Michael Zuber he doesn't edit and he he
interviews Clips related to finances
he's at 10,000
uploads
in a shorter time than both you and I
but the content format is just like
quick conversations he cuts a clip he
uploads it it's it's a high volume kind
of play but with all the work and all of
the the time and all of the things that
people don't see I just want to
acknowledge you too just for what you've
put in how you serve people the love and
the positivity and the energy that comes
through your videos over a decade uh for
what it's worth I give you permission
that you did it need but I I encourage
to go big it's a thousand uploads y'all
should really celebrate go on vacation
to you should make it you should do
something for multiple weeks something
for your subscribers something for
yourself um that's going to be a really
big milestone with all the work that
you've been doing over the years well
thank you for that Sean I think that
what you just said though is so true and
I think regardless of where you are in
your creator Journey whether you're just
starting or you've been do I know at
this a few years to like really Champion
your milestones and to like step back
and be like wow like this is really
going great um and sometimes it's even
as simple as like I don't know like
keeping a little journal or writing it
down or you know going back to you know
sometimes I go back and like look at my
planner or old videos and whatever and
I'm like oh yeah like there's been a lot
of growth since then like look at what's
happened because it is easy to forget to
do that you're right when you're so
focused on the day today 100% okay we're
gonna go to our new segment in just a
second but yeah before we get there um
this would be your time to shout it out
how could people connect with you follow
up with what you're doing of course
we'll link it up in the show notes where
are you at so
youtube.com/ doit on a dime and I'm doit
on a dime on all platforms at doit on a
dime um and I post weekly videos and
many many shorts as we've discussed
amazing and so definitely check out show
notes all right this segment is called
repeat after me and so I'll say this say
uh the sentence you of course repeat the
first part and then fill in the blank
with whatever comes to mind if I was
starting on YouTube from from zero today
the first thing I would do is upload a
short video short form video you got to
repeat this the opening
line oh I have to say I see I here's
here's now uh some insight for listeners
to to why we do this segment they should
steal it because this is a list of short
form that we may cut out because you're
gonna tee up the hook um by repeating
the opening sentence Oh yes all right
just but I mean so so it's it's a fun
segment it gives us those bite-size tips
for of course our podcast Community um
but for what it's worth that's the
reason for the segment I haven't shared
that that's right see when you mess up
sometimes the learning thing comes out
of it I love this awesome yes yes okay
so we've got five of them and here we go
so if I was starting on YouTube from
zero today the first thing I would do is
if I was starting on YouTube from zero
today the first thing I would do is pick
up a camera have a great hook and create
a 30 second short form video explaining
exactly what I do and giving people a
reason to stay the biggest mistake I see
new creators making is the biggest
mistake I see creators making is feeling
like they have to have it right out the
Gat I think if you are consistently
making content it becomes right as you
make it and you start to see what your
audience is resonating with the level up
happens slowly it does not happen right
away for any body any creator that you
see that has quote unquote made it had
to start off making a lot of mistakes to
get there if you're feeling afraid to
get on camera here's what I recommend if
you're feeling afraid to get on camera
here is what I'd recommend take three
takes the first take that you do you're
just experimenting and you're just
trying it out right the second take I
want you to do the same thing that you
said and give it a little bit more
energy and then the third take make
yourself a little bit uncomfortable be
more energetic or give more of yourself
or try something that maybe you thought
felt a little weird to do you're going
to surprise yourself when you play that
back that a lot of times what reads in
real life as too much on camera reads as
just right once you start to succeed on
YouTube the next skill you should start
developing is once you start to succeed
on YouTube the next skill you should
start developing is to figure out why
you are successful because it's one
thing to have a video pop off and go
viral but if you can answer the question
why get curious about why people are
showing up to your content and
specifically point it out and do it
again if you stay curious in this
business you cannot help but be
successful finally the most important
mindset you need for long-term success
on YouTube is the most important mindset
you need for long-term success on
YouTube is recognizing
any type of failure is a touchstone of
growth and an opportunity to Pivot every
single time that I've gotten burnt out
or felt like oh my gosh I don't know
what I'm supposed to do next I look back
at all of those seasons and I go that
was where the new thing started so when
something stops working and you get
curious about it and you're like hey
what am I going to do next that's how
you stay at this game a long time
Catherine do it on a dime thank you so
much for coming on the think media
podcast thank you for having me Sean it
was an honor